now let's explore custom Training
custom Training lets you code your own
ml environment to control the entire ml
development process starting from data
preparation to model deployment
if you want to code your machine
learning model you can use this option
by building a custom Training solution
with vertex AI workbench workbench is a
single development environment for the
entire data science workflow from
exploring to training and then deploying
a machine learning model with code
before any coding begins you must
determine what environment you want your
ml training code to use
there are two options a pre-built
container or a custom container
imagine that a container is a kitchen a
pre-built container would represent a
fully furnished room with cabinets and
appliances which represent the
dependencies this includes all the
cookware which represents the libraries
you need to make a meal
so if your ml training needs a platform
like tensorflow pytorch scikit-learn or
xgboost and python code to work with the
platform a pre-built container is
probably your best solution
a custom container alternatively is like
an empty room with no cabinets
appliances or cookware you define the
exact tools that you need to complete
the job